what happens if you have cancer and
every time you go to the doctor he says
well just drink just rest and drink
water you've only got a cold you know in
each case you need to understand what is
a specific type of disaster you know in
in in the decade after 2008 I was
constantly betting on low interest rates
but Co was a situation interjects were
likely to rise so in that case I bet on
a massive increase in the gold price the
way that it manifests can be different
in each occasion but the crisis itself
in my opinion is being driven by
inequality the trick about trading is
not about
being right it's about being right when
other people are wrong and I think this
this massive growth in inequality you
know historians will look back at our
time and say this was a period where the
economy was being driven by Massive
growth inequality but economists in the
present have not yet understood that
which means that you have these massive
tectonic plate shifts driving everything
generally not being understood by
Traders and markets